you can never kill me because I'm too
Pro oh wow he alright longest spike fall
I don't think it matters how long it's
gonna be because I'm gonna win cuz
that's how I do actually that is how I
do on most of these you like that sound
of my death hotdogs car pop wheelies
Onam accelerate reverse lean forward
let's go with my amazing hot dog car
don't need it's love a nice big wiener
flax into a nice button and then while
it in this ketchup right here and then
you just use it to Ola get right into
your mouth and oh that won't break let
me just slam my wiener into that chain a
little harder till it pricks it's gonna
there we go
thought I could stop me but it didn't
the static until them all you say what
hey what about it it's all wah it's over
when Sara was my blood jet fall well
well well let's just see what we have
here a tea or this ain't hard is ain't
hard at all
oh wow wow whoa hey Walden I almost made
that
my heart whoa
take a Chuck Norris all right we're
gonna try to escape at a box how do we
let's see if I think about this quietly
I can do this
like just present my ass oh it's
something break behind me I couldn't
even tell nor do I care about whatever
may or may not have happened behind me
that nope didn't care
run from what run from once didn't hurt
what you think I care you think I give
two asses I don't even give three asses
no don't hurt cool rope swing how cool
bruh well skills challenge okay let's
see what you got glass break alright
whatever don't matter Mike jump wow that
was hard
oh no it was guy what oh no didn't hurt
watch you kill my son like I can whoop
ride ain't nothin
what foot he crazy I don't even know
what that means let me guess you're
gonna forget there's gonna be a bottle
run at the end and that got me in the
face but I don't care you think I care
does it look like I care all right let's
see the ball throw come on give me the
balls and whoop what oh no always
awesome course number so oh boy I
remember you
let's carry on the dope oh [ __ ] god damn
it alright let's try this again now
shall we excuse me
oh alright let's try this one more time
excuse me God
tablet brewski miss don't care kid you
need to stop don't know what [ __ ] you
stupid Paul get out of here no one cares
about you
apparently you don't hurt me so screw
you face screw you oh crap no my tire
you [ __ ] you bash my tire in you son ow
owie
okay let's try to go there go No ah my
pelvis how about we do this again like
this Oh God is it the Zap zu bit about
did I lose some whoa oh my whoa that
almost hurt a little bit something
seemed to have gone wrong no I'm fine
didn't even hurt didn't even hurt okay
we'll wait our turn and then we'll go
real fast real fast
meow oh no aah take a million and five
balls God oh we got
look at that everything is hunky-dory
over here sounds good to me you ain't
gonna hurt me get out of here you no one
cares about you
oh not my tire god damn it you effed up
my tire you bastard
how am I supposed to have any propulsion
if I go like this hey I better wait here
I'm gonna wait here and till it's time
to go can you could you go
no you bro ahh I'm gonna get this son of
a [ __ ] you see I died I'm not going to
die I refuse I prove I'm strong my son
may not be but then I think my wife
cheated on me with the mailman and
that's why he's a weak son of a [ __ ]
okay I'm small into the beach my friends
yeah there we go super booster try to do
a double front flip that didn't even
trigger I'm so great and then we go as
fast fast as possible as fast as
possible okay this is the last chance to
have a black minigames oh boy kill the /
oh no one saw anything about that nonce
I think I did it fine one saw anything
again
mother fudge balls
oh there we go
hold up whoa whoa let me go look at me
go I'm still not gonna win it although I
get to hold the button pushes the button
you died so horribly that was awful it's
disgusting the way you died with all the
blood well well well a ball throw you
say my old arch nemesis I can't even
grab onto the balls anyone have that
problem
Luke Ingram
[Music]
[Music]
fifteen seconds
okay kitties we did to quickly get into
evasive maneuvers oh no whoa hey I don't
even need to finish level I'm gonna go
flying I believe I can fall laughs OH
Spike's pod
[Laughter]
what there's no more this has been happy
wheels highlights thanks for watching if
you liked the video and want to see more
why not subscribe today want to help the
channel grow
leave a like add it to your favorites or
share with your friends on Facebook and
Twitter thanks again and as always I
will see you in the next video
[Music]